[Music]  we couldn't film at the real wash in  mind met but we built very impressive  very large chunks of the monument for  filming Jorge cobbles our stunt  coordinator and he's excellent  he knew what tom was capable of he  designed the stunts in such a way that  we could really capture them not just  from a spectacle standpoint but also  capture the emotion thank you today was  our first day of spider-man climbing  we've got him on our slightly pitched  war movie magic and we're gonna be  climbing Tom for the first time on the  wall we've done a lot of rehearsal on  this so hopefully he'll make us all into  it okay Tom stays you are there and  we're gonna walk you across we didn't  have to like film it sideways we didn't  have to turn the camera sideways and see  how it looked afterwards we could see it  immediately and I could see myself an  angle myself to make sure I get the best  position  yeah  [Music]